honoring a life taken far too soon the
vigil was held tonight for
seven-year-old liam houston
it's a case we've been following for
over two weeks thank you so much for
joining us tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis liam houston's body was
found on a hiking trail outside of las
vegas
last month tonight family friends and
supporters gathered to celebrate liam's
life at sunset park
madison kimbra was there and joins us in
studio with more
madison tonight's visual was a red and
white affair as people gathered in his
favorite colors
this story has caught the attention of
so many around the country and this
evening
liam's father spoke out and is reacting
to the devastating news
i'm still in shock you know i still
don't want to believe it
liam houstead's father speaks out after
a vigil was held for his son sunday
evening at sunset park
the las vegas community coming together
to honor the seven-year-old boy
whose body was found just over two weeks
ago on a hiking trail outside of las
vegas
you know to take him under your wing
like he was your own
when i wasn't able to be here with him
you know really means a lot to me and i
know he
i know he appreciates it people from all
around vegas came out in liam's favorite
colors red and white with balloons and
bubbles in hand
a celebration of life hosted by a las
vegas local who has been following the
story from the start
you know they asked if i would help put
the event together and
of course i'm not going to say no i have
kids of my own so it hits close to home
andre crockett another las vegas
resident who owns a funeral home says
the number of cases he has seen with
children
dying is unnerving he says he came out
today to pay his respects
throughout the years we deal with a lot
of
children who die at the hands of adults
and children don't have a voice
police believe liam's mother samantha
moreno rodriguez took liam's life in the
las vegas area
but the case spans at least three states
california nevada
and colorado here's a seven-year-old
nobody really knew who he was
they didn't know a name for him when
they first
found him and no one was reporting a
missing child
currently moreno rodriguez is being held
in police custody in denver she is yet
to be transferred here to las vegas
and liam's father created a gofundme
page and it's already exceeded its goal
of 20 thousand dollars
and continues to grow we have a link to
that up on our website
reporting live in studio madison
kimbrough 8 news now